we have said that the Bernoulli process
is the simplest stochastic process there
is but what is a stochastic process
anyway the stochastic process can be
thought of as a sequence of random
variables now how is this different what
we have doing before where we have dealt
with multiple random variables
well one difference is that here we're
talking about an infinite sequence of
random variables and that complicates
things to a certain extent now what does
it take to describe a stochastic process
we should specify the properties of each
one of those random variables for
example we might be interested in the
mean variance or PMF of those random
variables for the case of the Bernoulli
process this would be easy to do we know
what the expected value is we have a
formula for the variance and we have a
fairly simple PMF there's probability P
that X is equal to 1 and probability 1
minus P that x equals to 0 but this is
not enough we also need to know how the
different random variables are related
to each other and this is done by
specifying directly or indirectly the
joint distribution the joint PMF or PDF
of the random variables involved and
because we have an infinite number of
random variables it's not enough to do
this let's say for the first ten of them
we need to be able to specify this joint
distribution no matter what the number n
is for the case of the Bernoulli process
we have specified this joint PMF in an
indirect way because we have said that
the random variables are independent of
each other so the joint factors as a
product of the marginals and we already
know what the marginals are so we do
indeed have a specification of the joint
PMF and we have that for all values of n
of course for more complicated
stochastic processes this calculation
might be somewhat more difficult now
there is a second view of a stochastic
process which rests of the fall
it's not just a collection of random
variables but they're a collection
that's indexed by an index that keeps
increasing and quite often we think of
this index as corresponding to time and
so we have a mental picture that
involves a process that keeps evolving
in time what is this picture this
picture is best developed if we think in
terms of a sample space although we have
an infinite sequence of random variables
we are dealing with a single experiment
and that single experiment runs in time
and when we carry out the experiment we
might get an outcome such as the
following for the Bernoulli process we
might get a zero zero one zero one one
zero and so on and we continue so an
infinite sequence of that kind is one
possible outcome of this infinitely long
experiment one particular outcome of the
stochastic process if we carry out the
process once more we might get a
different outcome for example we might
get a 0 1 1 0 0 0 1 1 and so on
and continuing and in general any time
function of this kind is one possible
outcome of the experiment overall the
sample space that we're dealing with is
the set of all infinite sequences of
zeros and ones
this point of view emphasizes the fact
that we have a phenomenon that evolves
over time and can be used to answer
questions that have to do with the long
term evolution of this process here's
one particular kind of question we might
want to answer what is the probability
that all of the X eyes turn out to be
one notice that this is an event that
involves all of the X eyes not just a
finite number of them so this is not a
probability that we can calculate right
away by using this joint PMF we need to
do a little more work what is the work
that we want to do instead of
calculating this quantity we will
calculate a somewhat related quantity
let us look at the event that the first
n results were equal to 1 how is this
event related to this event well this
event here implies that this event has
happened so this is a smaller event this
is more difficult to obtain than this
one and this gives us an inequality for
the probabilities that go this way now
we know that this probability is equal
to P to the N and this inequality here
is true for all n no matter how large
and we take this quantity is smaller
than that but now since P has been
assumed to be less than 1 when we take n
larger and larger this number becomes
arbitrarily small so this quantity is
less than or equal to an arbitrarily
small number so this quantity can only
be equal to 0 and this is a simple
example of how we calculate properties
of the stochastic process as it evolves
over the infinite time horizon and how
we can sometimes calculate them using
these so-called finite dimensional joint
probabilities that tell us what the
process is doing
a finite amount of time throughout we
will sometimes view stochastic processes
in this matter in terms of probability
distributions but sometimes we will also
want to reason in terms of the behavior
of the stochastic process as a time
function as a process that evolves in
time